The paper here says that the economy is set for an upturn.
I hope so,..
...but you know you can't believe everything that you read.
I suppose.  Still, it's always good to read something encouraging.
That's true.
I think the stock market hasn't been doing all that well of late.
No, it hasn't.
Both the NASDAQ and the New York Stock Exchange have been in the doldrums for a while now.
I think that the government hasn't done a very good job of managing the economy, either.
Well, it's all interconnected.
The economy as a whole could definitely use a shot in the arm.
There's an old saying,...
..."What goes up must come down, and vice versa."
So "what goes down" must also come up, then?
Exactly. I wouldn't worry too much about it.
Besides, when stocks are low, it's the best time to buy, right?
Maybe, but I'm going to hold on to my money for a while yet.